let's face it when you're trying to get
god to intervene on your behalf silent
prayer is only going to get you so far
so it was only a matter of time until
someone sued god according to many
religious traditions god created the
universe so really when you think about
it it's only fair that he or she should
pay for the damages that they've caused
and in fact the last part of a complaint
the thing that starts a lawsuit is
called a prayer for relief and that is
not a coincidence except that it
completely is just a coincidence so
let's look at some instances where
people have tried to bring god and satan
to justice the first is where a man sued
satan and his staff for his own problems
in 1971 gerald mayo filed a class-action
lawsuit against satan and his staff
because i guess like any small business
owner satan relies on clerical workers
to dot the eyes and cross the t's mayo a
22 year old inmate at western
penitentiary in pittsburgh allege the
following quote satan has on numerous
occasions cause plaintiff misery and
unwanted threats against the will of
plaintiff that satan has placed
deliberate obstacles in his path and
caused plaintiff's downfall and by
reason of these acts satan has deprived
him of his constitutional rights yes
that is an actual federal court case
mayo had filed his complaint in former
papers which in latin translates to in
the manner or character of a popper this
allows for an indian party to get court
costs waived and is most commonly used
by inmates filing suit however a federal
court will still reject a prisoner's
application under the following
circumstances that the allegation
of poverty is untrue the action is
frivolous or malicious the complaint
does not state a claim on which relief
can be granted or an inmate sues a
defendant for money damages and that
defendant is immune from liability for
money damages pennsylvania judge gerald
weber denied mayo's petition on the
third ground writing that this court has
serious doubts that the complaint
reveals a cause of action upon which
relief can be granted by the court in a
one-page order dripping with irony judge
weber detailed other issues mayo might
have had in regard to suing the prince
of darkness judge weber questioned
whether the court even has jurisdiction
to hear the case noting that mayo failed
to allege whether satan even lives in
the western district of pennsylvania
while noting that there is no official
case in which the devil has appeared as
a defendant judge weber jokingly
referred to quote an unofficial account
of a trial in new hampshire where this
defendant filed an action of mortgage
foreclosure as plaintiff this was a
reference to the short story the devil
and daniel webster where a farmer who
sells his soul to the devil is defended
before a jury of the damned by famous
19th century american statesman lawyer
and orator daniel webster though if
you're like me you're probably more
familiar with the treehouse of horror
story the devil and homer simpson might
sell my soul for a donut which is
basically exactly the same story in this
context judge webber noted without
deciding that as a foreign prince satan
might be able to claim sovereign
immunity to shield him from litigation
in rejecting this complaint judge weber
also highlighted another potential issue
namely that mayo could not satisfy the
requirements to bring a class action
lawsuit under federal rule of civil
procedure 23 judge weber noted that
while mayo might be able to meet the
first three requirements of a class
action suit the court was unable to
determine whether mayo could fairly
inadequately protect the interests of
the class that he was purporting to
represent and finally in denying mayo's
petition judge weber noted that mayo had
failed to provide specific instructions
to u.s marshals for how to serve satan
with a complaint but this lawsuit shows
why it's so hard to sue the devil all
these rules of civil procedure were
written by people who are already
working for the devil
lawyers but then there's the man who
tried to sue god to stop natural
disasters one of the most devastating
effects of climate change has been the
increase of severe weather events such
as flash flooding and more frequent and
destructive hurricanes and most of the
proposed solutions for dealing with
increasing natural disasters involve
regulating carbon and shifting to
renewable energy sources which are
boring but in 2007 one nebraska state
senator opted for a more direct approach
get a court order against god
prohibiting from any more destruction
entered nebraska state senator ernie
chambers who left office in 2021 after a
record 46 years in nebraska's
legislature
senator chambers is no stranger to
standing out among his more conservative
colleagues during his career he would
don a sweatshirt and jeans instead of a
jacket and tie and as an avowed agnostic
in the devout state senator chambers
made no secret of his lack of religious
faith in his 2007 complaint the senator
accused god of causing quote fearsome
floods horrendous hurricanes terrifying
tornadoes and of making terroristic
threats against the senator and his
constituents inspiring fear and causing
widespread death destruction and
terrorization of millions upon millions
of the earth's inhabitants and senator
chambers based his ability to sue god as
quote that defendant being omnipresent
is personally present in douglas county
and in his prayer for relief senator
chambers requested a permanent
injunction ordering defendant to cease
certain harmful activities and making
terroristic threats and in 2008 douglas
county district court judge marlon polk
threw out the lawsuit citing senator
chambers failure to personally serve god
with the complaint judge polk referring
to nebraska law that requires the
plaintiff to have access to the
defendant for a lawsuit to move forward
ruled that god's lack of a listed home
address was fatal to chambers's action
quote given that this court finds that
there can never be service effectuated
on the named defendant this action will
be dismissed with prejudice after the
ruling senator chambers who graduated
from law school but never took the bar
exam highlighted what he felt was a flaw
in the judge's reasoning that god had
not been properly served quote this
court itself acknowledges the existence
of a god a consequence of that
acknowledgement is a recognition of
god's omnipresence since god knows
everything god has notice of this
lawsuit which is kind of hilarious
because substitution of service through
notice of publication is actually a real
thing but you might be asking why would
an avid agnostic sue god in the first
place well he wanted to make a point
about the importance of an open court
system the nebraska state constitution
guarantees the right of the people to
seek relief in the courts as provided in
article 1 section 13 quote all courts
shall be open and every person for any
injury done to him or her in his or her
lands goods person or reputation shall
have a remedy by due course of law and
justice administered without denial or
delay senator chambers made clear that
he was not suing god due to any specific
beef with the deity and i remind you he
didn't even think that
god existed but rather his lawsuit was a
specific form of protest at the time
nebraska legislators were filing various
bills to curb so-called frivolous
lawsuits and senator chambers believe
that these laws violated the nebraska
constitution's guarantee of open courts
though sadly because this court refused
to issue an injunction floods and
hurricanes have continued and god
continues to evade american law
enforcement which takes us to the time
that a hippie commune tried to involve
god in a fraudulent conspiracy
the 1960s were a wild time of free love
mind altering drugs and rock and roll
all three of which could be found at the
morning star commune in occidental
california but when johnny law came to
the northern california hippie compound
after legal woes and health code
violations piled up the owner had a
unique solution deed his property to god
and make it his problem morningstar was
founded in 1966 by lou gottly bassist
for the american folk group the
limelighters an ex-communist with a phd
in musicology from uc berkeley gottlieb
came to believe that private property
was a sin and opened morningstar to
create a welcoming space for all comers
accordingly morningstar operated under
the acronymic credo latwedo land access
to which is denied no one this 31-acre
clothing optional farmland embodied the
pinnacle of the california hippie
movement but if you ask the neighbors
the compound's tents and tree houses
were a walking health safety and fire
code violation and soon gottlieb's legal
troubles began to pile up with
morningstar's numerous health and
building violations ultimately leading
to fines totaling nearly eighteen
thousand five hundred dollars
approximately a hundred and forty
thousand dollars in today's money
they're hippies they don't have any
money sonoma county even ordered all
people to vacate the commune and in an
effort to end his legal troubles
gottlieb offered to donate morningstar
to the county but was refused but then
in may 1969 gottlieb came up with a
creative solution he deeded the property
to the almighty himself gottlieb argued
that god owned the property so it was
now god's problem to deal with the fines
and code violations but in july 1970
superior court judge kenneth eiman
rejected gottlieb's novel legal theory
the law the judge wrote requires the
quote the grantee must be a person
either natural or artificial in
existence at the time of the conveyance
and capable of taking title and
accordingly since gottlieb could not
affirmatively prove that god was a
natural person or entity the judge
reasoned god had no property rights in
the state of california judge eiman then
voided the deed and invalidated the
property transfer and by 1971 bulldozers
were sent to level nearly every building
on the ranch gottlieb passed away in
1996 and the land is still owned by his
heirs to this day all of whom are
corporeal people actually existing in
real life and show no signs of
omnipresence or omnipotence but you can
get closer to omnipotence by listening
to more audiobooks with today's sponsor
audible even if you have no intention of
suing god or satan you should listen to
john grisham's new legal thriller the
judges list on audible it's the story of
investigator lacey stultz as she follows
the trail of a serial killer and closes
in on a shocking suspect a sitting judge
he's the most cunning of all serial
killers because he knows forensics
police procedure and most importantly
the law honestly i was going to make a
joke about grisham but that sounds
pretty awesome and fun i use audible
almost every day it's by far the best
source of audio entertainment i listen
to audiobooks when i'm running cleaning
up or when i'm supposed to be listening
to friends and loved ones audible is the
leading provider of spoken word
entertainment all in one place if you
tried to listen to everything it would
take you three centuries and as an
audible member you get one credit every
month good for any title in the entire
premium selection which includes
basically every bestseller new release
or memoir those titles are yours to keep
forever in your audible library you'll
also get full access to their popular
plus catalog which is filled with
thousands and thousands of audiobooks
original entertainment guided fitness
and meditation sleep tracks and shows
all included with your membership no
credits required and right now audible
is running a special promo for legal
eagles new audible members will get a
free trial for 30 days you can try it
out and see why everyone including
myself loves audible all you have to do
is click on the link that's on screen
right now or in the description or go to
audible.com legaleagle so right now for
a limited time a free one-month trial of
audible just by clicking on the links on
screen plus clicking on that link really
helps out this channel and while you're
at it click on this playlist over here
with all my other legal entertainment
videos so click on this playlist or i'll
see you in court